professor Novak is Florence robots
professor visiting professor and
director of the governance lab at Yale
Law School
she's the Gerry Halton global network
professor at New York University's
Tandon School of Engineering and
director of the gov lab and it's
MacArthur research Network on opening
governance professor Novick focuses her
research teaching and activism on the
impact of technology on public
institutions and solving public problems
a graduate of Harvard University and
Yale Law School welcome home
she she is a member of the advisory
board of the open contracting
partnership and his program committee
member at the 2016 conferences on
international open data open data
research data science for government and
the data for good exchange welcome Thank
You Lindsay don't have a deck here no no
we'll just change I have this for other
reasons I'll tell you what I'll start
well if you don't mind bring no I'll let
you put my deck up and that way we'll so
I am
let me start it's under Novak I hope or
somewhere by saying I am delighted to be
here and I'm here first and foremost
just to meet the people in the room and
to enjoy the fellowship of people who
have so much in common and also to
report because it wasn't on the list
that was up earlier that we now have an
open data clinic at Yale Law School as
well where we have lots of students
working on and eager to work on open
data related policy projects so I'm here
a little bit as the lawyer in the room I
don't all now leave it once but to talk
about the legal and ethical and policy
side of some of this work again there's
a lot that has already been covered so I
will try not to repeat unduly but I want
to pick up on a point that was made
earlier perhaps in jest so I was the
head of open government and open data at
OSTP so you have me to blame for some of
those unfunded
mandates and the throwaway comment that
you made about the the end of open
science and open government and open
data in the White House I want to make
sure to bring that back to the fore
because though it was funny as we know
it's really not funny and so I want to
make sure that we're at least focused on
and the one thing that we take away from
this is that as much as we're excited
about the technologies of Big Data as
much as we're eager to talk as we will
today and as the students showed
yesterday about the many important
things we can do with the data that's
available it's not simply the tools that
are making possible everything we're
talking about it's the policies that
underlie them and that obviously runs
through the conversation so it's the
fact that we now have a policy of open
data at the national level in the United
States and that next week 70 countries
will meet for the open government
partnership in Paris 70 countries who
have signed on to commitments to open up
their data to create data portals at the
National at the state at the local level
15 of those countries have now signed on
to an international open data charter in
which they are making commitments what
I'm looking for is the exact language
which I won't find at the moment in
which they're going to make commitments
to essentially publish all data in
digital format downloadable open to the
public a priori so we still have a long
way to go to realize the vision but at
least we have the cornerstone in terms
of policy that started with the
President Obama's memorandum on his very
first day in office a memorandum on
transparency and open government in
which he said that data the data
collected by the government paid for our
attack by our taxpayer dollars collected
in the government's practice as
regulator and as researcher belongs to
us it was very controversial I might add
at the time it seems obvious to us now
but it was very controversial the idea
that we weren't simply focusing on data
about the workings of government such as
the money that it spends or the salaries
of public officials but that in fact we
would try to open up all the data that
could power things like the innovations
that we are talking about today and then
go
beyond the idea of just a policy of just
words the creation of platforms that
actually allow us to point to put data
somewhere to have a place for people to
find that data so that we can go beyond
the promise and make the practice real
in principle there's great things that
it's allowing us to do in terms of
transforming how government works so
when they put up the school spending
data in Mexico on mejora tu escuela we
can see right away that fifteen hundred
and twelve people all on the payroll all
have the same birth date they're all a
hundred and two years old and they all
make more than the President of Mexico
so it allows us to yes improve
government accountability but it also in
the end allows parents to make better
choices and ultimately it's not a story
about the data and it's not a story
about the platforms even as we know and
as you Sowell pointed out it's about the
communities that we build around the
data so in Rajasthan in India the group
mkss has for the last decade been taking
government spending data budget data and
painting it on the walls of villages and
holding readings theatrical performances
in which they read the budget if that
doesn't sound exciting I don't know what
does but what they do is then they ask
people where is the bridge built to
nowhere where is the person who's died
who's still on the payroll and through
that mechanism using data as the raw
material co-create the process of
co-create the process and the practice
of greater accountability in government
so I want to just spend a couple of
minutes on talking about another sort of
development you're all very familiar
with kind of the movement around open
data the one though that I want to
emphasize that we have to continue to
fight for we cannot especially now take
it as a given or take it for granted the
two leading countries the US and the UK
that spearheaded this movement have both
had a change of administration neither
of which seemed poised to invest in this
agenda that's a best-case scenario is
that they ignore it but we all know that
the reality is that we might see
significant rollbacks on the opening up
of data and investments in open data
since it costs real money to actually do
it well we
are seeing though is a rise of what many
people call social corporate data
philanthropy or what we call data
collaborative Bloomberg just had a big
conference on data science for social
good in which many companies came
committing to open up their data and we
know that part of the clinical trials
story part of what so many people in
this room have been fighting for is to
not only get the clinical trials data
from NIH but to also get it directly
from the companies that are producing
this data so you know it's Twitter
providing its firehose of data to the
University of Walla Gong in Australia
and then using that the university using
that to create flood maps to help
promote resilience excuse me in
Indonesia so we're seeing lots of ways
in which open data including data that
comes from government data that comes
from researchers data that comes from
companies through collaboration often
between these three parties that's what
we call data collaboratives it's at that
intersection that a lot of exciting work
is happening I only have a few minutes
today to talk about this so I would
point you to a website that we've
created called OD impact open datas
impact where we're collecting case
studies and in-depth stories but also
then analysis of these examples of open
data we have another project with USAID
focused on those that work in the
development context as well that's all
going up here and I might add to your
point this is fully open source and
replicable and a number of people have
already forked this to create their own
archives and repositories of open data
impact stories since so much of this
work as you said earlier is about
telling the story of impact not just
talking about the promise so I want to
fly through a couple of examples that
again
I think for you this is a room that
needs no convincing but I think it's
important to at least share a little bit
of the story about the ways in which we
are transforming not only science but
we're transforming government and other
sectors through open data and then to
end with a couple of just thoughts on
the policy side of this so obviously we
can do lots of great stuff now in terms
of our ability to provide services
especially to vulnerable people by
monitor
populations in real-time so when we open
up things like the National Oceanic and
Atmospheric data we can do things like
better predict the weather and a lot of
that data though some of its coming from
the government as we know but some of
that data also then comes from companies
so it's Intel opening up data that
collects off of sensors that it's using
and the combination of data is allowing
us to create new tools that help to
promote resilience we can as we saw with
the mejora to escuela example also
improve how government spends money and
government efficiency and government
effectiveness as was mentioned I'm on
the board of a non-profit called the
open contracting partnership with works
with governments around the world -
opening up open up their contracting and
spending data by the way the data is
open but we need people to look at it
and use it if we're going to actually
spot the fraud waste and abuse at the
very least what it's starting to do is
to decrease a culture of corruption in
places like Slovakia the Ukraine which
interestingly is very out ahead in last
year on open contracting data and Mexico
and elsewhere but we're seeing this move
towards government using its own data to
actually decrease its spending and
become more accountable we're seeing
then of course the ability to use this
data to solve major social problems so
we have problems hiding in plain sight
like that in Zanesville Ohio where when
you actually scrutinize the data you
discover that clean water is being
delivered there's a red lining problem
if you live in a neighborhood that is
white you're receiving clean city water
if you live in a neighborhood that's
traditionally african-american you are
not this led to then a lawsuit a change
in the situation damages to the that
were paid to the victims but it would
not have been possible without open data
about city water services about city
water practices that allow us then to
spot this kind of unfairness and to
rectify major social problems and so
we're also seeing obviously lots of use
of data collection and this is
particularly important where citizen
science comes in in terms of using
people on the ground as data collectors
we're seeing incidentally a lot of that
use of citizen
as data collectors now as monitors of
rises of hate incidents and bias
incidents as you've seen lots of efforts
by different groups to collect data
about hate crimes and rises of incidents
of hate that are occurring so the
collection of data particularly by
citizens that we can use when made open
as Christchurch New Zealand did to be
able then to figure out which buildings
are about to fall down where can people
move back in how do we actually rebuild
the city so the CIO of newsy of
Christchurch New Zealand was in fact
very out ahead on using open data and
then that collaboration and partnership
with citizens both to collect the data
but also to scrutinize the data to be
able to develop solutions in real times
in real time and again what you see is a
lot of this work happening now at the
intersection between government and
private companies because especially in
a lot of developing world contexts there
is no administrative state
infrastructure there isn't that data
being collected by government and so we
need to depend on the work of groups
like real impact analytics and Twitter
and others who have the data and push
them to make it available so that we can
do this kind of social good work more
efficiently and effectively my lab as a
partnership with UNICEF over the next
year and a half will be working we have
both worked to define the problems that
UNICEF works on in terms of improving
children's lives and then trying to find
the partners that we can turn to in
countries that don't have a census that
don't have a data collection
infrastructure or where we might a
create one using citizen scientists or
be use data that companies are anyway
collecting finally the last example that
I want to give and it's an example that
we frequently use when we have a hard
time convincing people of the need to
open up their data we can see how it
works with Provost's I know how it works
with Prime Minister's which is you tell
them not that open data is the right
thing to do you don't tell them about
solving social problems and helping
flood victims and and babies and
children you tell them it'll create jobs
and promote economic growth you tell
them about how New York City is using
open data to create a business Atlas
that gives the small business owner the
same kind of market research information
about where to site
jewelry store or their coffee shop as
the Starbucks or the gap has we have a
project called the open data 500 which
has been tracking and this by the way is
open ADA 500 is in the US and then we
have a bunch of other countries that
were partnered with labs and other
places tracking businesses that use open
data to create jobs and we're working
with scholars at Columbia Business
School to track the investment in those
businesses and their research shows that
in fact Oh business is driven by open
data perhaps surprisingly in fact
receive no less investment than people
who used closed assets and closed
resources in fact they do just as well
and there's a tremendous number of
exciting stories about how companies and
back to your point about creating the
commercial layer on top of these
services the fact that in this country
unlike in many others we have a policy
which says you can reuse the data
including for commercial purposes helps
to create jobs so let me just let me
sort of wind up I have no idea what time
it is we have a couple more nets so
ultimately I think the biggest benefit
and we know this from the science case
but we also see it as much in the
government case it's so both in terms of
reproducibility in all of these contexts
is what we do is we get more eyeballs on
a problem so by opening up the data we
can then get which one is this one we
can then get election watchers we can
then create a crowdsourcing project as
the koala pomelo project did using open
election data to then in a project that
I might add cost something on the order
of fifty seven dollars and was done in
about you know a week these stories are
also wonderful about how cheap they are
were then able to scrutinize election
results for fraud etc so let me I'm
going to skip ahead because I want to
talk about the challenges so how do we
realise this benefit whether in the
government context or in the science
context obviously we need to continue to
push and that's part of the that's the
entire impetus for this event today we
need to push for the policies against
data hugging disorder against data
hoarding disorder but we have to do it
in all of these sectors and we have to
do it in all of them in
and Mbeki the collaboration between them
if we're to realize the bed the social
benefits from having the data so we need
to keep pushing on the government side
but we need to also do this work and
with companies with research institutes
etc in order to realize these benefits
it's not though all a story about open
data right and we know very well
particularly for people who are doing
human subjects research who are doing
biomedical research this is also a story
about the Fifty Shades of Grey in
between closed and open namely
responsible data access and data
governance knowing how to share data in
reliable and responsible ways so I was
very proud that my students yesterday
got to present a poster on work that
they're doing with two jurisdictions now
in Lafayette Parish Louisiana and
Cottington County South Dakota on their
governance practices for sharing data
between their criminal justice and
mental health agencies helping them to
work through that process and develop a
toolkit and kind of a map for how to do
that so they can in turn reduce
incarceration by diverting the mentally
ill out of jail or prison and into
treatment that can only be done through
data sharing but that has to be done in
ways they're legally compliant that are
ethically compliant where they actually
know what I T to use unlike one of the
jurisdictions which simply emails a
spreadsheet of everybody from one agency
to another which we know is not the best
way to do it but is so there's a whole
range of issues that intertwine the
technical and the legal and the ethical
that are really questions of data
governance that are at the center of a
lot of the work that we see happening
there's fabulous work being done now by
the UN's Food Lab and the UN hunger
program on collecting data about Syrian
refugees and their consumption of food
in the camps but they can't simply
publish and visualize this data less
they make the people they're trying to
help potential targets and victims of
crime and a
so there are lots of difficult ethical
questions that people are debating and
in this country where we have launched
we announced it last year and about a
hundred and twenty years days ago the
checks were dispersed in the precision
medicine initiative we have this great
hope that we will start to collect
longitudinal data from a million people
not just about their genetics but now
about their cultural practices their
environmental practices what they do and
to do that data to collect it
effectively we have to know responsibly
how to handle it we it's great if we
have ten years of data on people that
can allow us to quickly spot that I
might be at the risk of diabetes but
it's terrible if by virtue of that
surveillance I suddenly start getting
coupons for Big Macs then we're doing
something wrong we're doing something
wrong if we're not then also putting the
people at the center of the process and
ensuring that in that research we are
prioritizing the needs and the
conditions of the people who are most
underserved and underrepresented in
biomedical research I'm glad to report
it that in the precision medicine
initiative they have taken extra steps
to create a national level IRB with a
high degree of diversity in that IRB to
ensure exactly that the people and their
privacy is putting put at the center so
let me stop because I want to make sure
we have some time for questions and just
say that as we talk about all the
fabulous things that we can do with big
data in the sciences that we must put
the policies of privacy of openness of
ethical and responsible sharing and of
governance at the center and so with all
that I make a case for the lawyers and
why we're very happy to be part of this
conversation thank you
[Applause]